[Música]
el domingo 25 de octubre de 2020 en
plena pandemia del coronavirus los
chilenos fueron llamados a votar para el
plebiscito nacional de 2020 un
referéndum que consultó a la ciudadanía
si querían que se redactará una nueva
constitución y de ser así quien quería
que lo hiciera este referéndum no fue ni
mucho menos uno más por dos motivos por
un lado se decidía el futuro del país
hasta el punto de estar en juego la
construcción de una nueva república
chilena que sería ya la sexta y además
se produce en medio de una oleada de
violencia desenfrenada de hecho pocos
días antes de la votación veíamos
noticias como estas las protestas
violentas resurgen en chile- a dos
semanas del plebiscito por una nueva
constitución el 19 de octubre de 2020
queman dos iglesias en santiago de chile
tras una jornada de protestas y no no es
algo reciente o meramente coyuntural la
situación que atraviesa chile desde hace
ya más de un año se ha cobrado la vida
de al menos 36 personas y dejado tras de
sí casi 9.000 arrestos son disturbios
cuyo fin hoy por hoy pues no se percibe
en el horizonte claro que a tenor de los
resultados arrojados por el plebiscito
constitucional en el que más del 78 por
ciento de los votos
y han apoyado una nueva constitución
podríamos pensar que la sociedad chilena
busca de una vez por todas pasar página'
y restablecer la paz social con una
nueva norma suprema ahora bien porque
quieren los chilenos una nueva
constitución que tiene de malo la actual
cómo funciona el proceso constituyente
en chile- para llevar a cabo este
proceso es realmente este un buen
momento para lanzarse a esta aventura
queridos amigos en este vídeo vamos a
contestar a estas y otras preguntas
atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
si hay algo innegable y por lo que puede
que a muchos os llame la atención el
cambio es que bajo la actual
constitución chile ha logrado los
mayores estándares de desarrollo y nivel
de vida de toda américa latina una
región donde la pobreza continúa siendo
generalizada y donde desgraciadamente
las cosas al menos en el corto plazo
pues no pintan nada pero que nada bien
así que el dilema en este caso sería es
la economía lo único que importa pues
para un 78% de los chilenos la respuesta
parece haber sido clara y contundente no
no es lo único que importa de hecho los
motivos para querer una nueva
constitución son muy amplios pero
podríamos resumir los en que el actual
de 1980 fue creada por una dictadura y
fue concebida con un objetivo
autoritario muy diferente al modelo
político del actual chile tanto es así
que hasta el propio presidente sebastián
piñera y su partido han apoyado el
apruebo en este referéndum
[Música]
a pesar de que la actual constitución ha
recibido 31 modificaciones desde 1980
los días bastante importantes en 1989 y
2005 lo cierto es que el gran dilema
parece estar además de en partes de su
contenido en la forma mediante la cual
se aprobó y en qué contexto político y
social se redactó y aunque lo cierto es
que bajo esta constitución han sido
amplia mayoría los gobiernos de
centroizquierda entre ellos ocho de la
socialista michelle bachelet el que se
ha garantizado un funcionamiento más que
aceptable de las instituciones
democráticas el problema con ella está
sobre todo en las estructuras de estado
que apuntala unas estructuras que
favorecen la estabilidad pero que
complica muchísimo prácticamente
cualquier reforma política sustancial
reformas que estarían plenamente
aceptadas en otras democracias
de hecho uno de los grandes problemas
políticos de américa latina es
precisamente este por regla general sus
constituciones y leyes han ido agregando
derechos sociales a sus textos a medida
que se producían protestas pero se han
asegurado de no tocar los numerosos
privilegios políticos contemplados para
las élites unas rígidas élites que se
perpetúan generación tras generación
pero eso ya hablaremos en otro vídeo la
cuestión es que todo este cambio que se
ha puesto en marcha en chile- está
generando un enorme mar de dudas sobre
cuál puede ser el resultado último de la
nueva constitución chilena claro que
antes de entrar a valorar esta cuestión
es mejor echarle un ojo a la actual
constitución de 1980 para entender por
qué envían tres ya no le gusta a los
chilenos amigos la pregunta es está
justificado este próximo cambio
constitucional
[Música]
los problemas de la constitución de 1980
si hay algo polémico y controvertido en
la constitución de 1980 creada impulsada
por el régimen dictatorial de augusto
pinochet es precisamente su legitimidad
sí es cierto de alguna forma a la carta
magna- quedó legítima de facto con el
tiempo mediante un montón de
modificaciones y también por haber sido
la cobertura legal de diferentes
gobiernos democráticos pero la realidad
es que lo que rodea el texto no deja de
ser hiriente para muchos chilenos además
de polémico y de hecho algunos expertos
interpretan el sentimiento de los
chilenos hacia su ley básica hacia su
carta magna- de esta manera es como
alguien que tiene una casa hermosa pero
ya no la quiere porque fue construida
por un padre que fue un violador no es
que la casa esté mal es que él ha
construido ese padre patricio navia
profesor de estudios latinoamericanos y
caribeños de la universidad de nueva
york además el principal ideólogo de la
constitución de 1980 el político jurista
y académico jaime guzmán la diseño de
una forma por la que fuera especialmente
complicado acometer reformas políticas
de calado
[Música]
los objetivos de guzmán eran por tanto
sino conservar la totalidad del régimen
político de pinochet una vez hubiera un
cambio si al menos el mantener las
estructuras el diseño el caparazón del
estado tal y como estaba de hecho una de
las citas más conocidas de jaime guzmán
respecto al objetivo de su construcción
institucional es precisamente este
atentos la constitución debe procurar
que si llegan a gobernar los adversarios
serían constreñidos a seguir una acción
no tan distinta a la que uno mismo
anhelaría para que el margen de
alternativas que la cancha les imponga a
quienes juegan en ella sea lo
suficientemente reducido como para ser
extremadamente difícil lo contrario
jaime guzmán ideólogo de la constitución
chilena de 1980 fijaos un buen ejemplo
de todo esto lo tenemos en el artículo 9
ese artículo es prácticamente una
excepción en las constituciones de todo
el mundo habla específicamente del
terrorismo y termina una serie de
prohibiciones ojo en la propia carta
magna para cualquier persona que sea
declarada como tal como terrorista luego
es una ley de mayoría reforzada la que
determina bajo qué supuestos eres o no
declarado como terrorista pero el
peligro de ese artículo no es ese
[Aplausos]
y es que veréis me explico fijaos en
algunas de las prohibiciones que se
establecen para estos supuestos
terroristas
los responsables quedarán inhabilitados
por el plazo de 15 años para ejercer
funciones o cargos públicos sean o no de
elección popular o de rector o director
de establecimiento de educación o para
ejercer en ellos funciones de enseñanza
para explotar un medio de comunicación
social o ser director o administrador
del mismo ni podrán ser dirigentes de
organizaciones políticas o relacionadas
con la educación o de carácter vecinal
profesional empresarial sindical
estudiantil o gremial en general durante
dicho plazo artículo 9 de la
constitución de chile- a ver
evidentemente aquí y nadie está a favor
del terrorismo ni de no condenar a
terroristas pero la cuestión es que es
un terrorista sí vale eso es lo que fija
la ley de mayoría reforzada pero la mera
existencia de ese artículo es toda una
ventana abierta a que llegado el caso
una mayoría política pudiera determinar
que no sé terrorista es algo muy
diferente a lo que todos estamos
pensando y desde luego también era muy
diferente a lo que el régimen de
pinochet tenía en mente cuando
redactaron este artículo ha llegado el
caso de este artículo podría ser
utilizado por un presidente autoritario
para eliminar de la vida pública no sólo
a la oposición política sino también a
cualquier el ciudadano disidente
de sus empleos públicos de ser
profesores o ejercer la libertad de
prensa por poner un ejemplo y esto esto
es sólo una muestra de cómo esta
constitución tiene sus raíces una
impronta muy distinta a lo que estamos
acostumbrados a ver en las democracias
más avanzadas pero desde luego eso no es
ni muchísimo menos lo peor
y luego el poder que le otorga el
presidente es inmenso mucho mayor al de
otras repúblicas unitarias con sistemas
presidencialistas por poneros un ejemplo
el artículo 65 de la carta magna-
chilena atribuye ojo en exclusiva al
presidente de la republica a tomar la
iniciativa de cosas como estas fijaos
imponer suprimir reducir o condenar
tributos de cualquier clase o naturaleza
crear nuevos servicios públicos o empleo
rentados fijar modificar conceder o o
aumentar remuneraciones jubilaciones
pensiones montepíos rentas y cualquier
otra clase de monumentos establecer las
modalidades y procedimientos de la
negociación colectiva establecer o
modificar las normas sobre seguridad
social artículo 65 de la constitución de
chile exacto como habéis escuchado sólo
el presidente puede emprender la
iniciativa de por ejemplo no se suprimir
un impuesto o subirlo bajar lo crear uno
nuevo o modificar las pensiones o normas
sobre la seguridad social y si el
presidente no quiere pues no se puede
diga lo que diga el parlamento lo que
vale tiene sus beneficios y sus
inconvenientes
[Música]
por ejemplo algunos partidarios de esta
construcción entre ellos muchos
liberales defienden que estas
iniciativas exclusivas son positivas en
tanto en cuanto favorecen la disciplina
fiscal además de limitar y evitar los
conflictos políticos electorales que
pudieran afectar a muchos legisladores
ya sabéis que en chile los presidentes
no tienen la posibilidad de presentarse
a la reelección consecutiva sin embargo
parece que la mayoría política y social
no lo tiene tan claro y en cualquier
caso son poderes mayores que los que se
suelen conceder a los presidentes de las
democracias más desarrolladas porque no
se trata de si el presiente tiene o no
veto sino que la iniciativa es
exclusivamente suya en cualquier caso lo
que está claro más allá del debate
político jurídico es que como veíamos
antes parece una clara reminiscencia de
otra época donde el presidente de
gobierno tenía todos los poderes sea
como sea lo que es un hecho es que los
chilenos tendrán una constitución
completamente nueva y el proceso para
lograrla se llevará a cabo mediante lo
que se conoce como un proceso
constituyente ahora bien como es ese
proceso y qué limitaciones tiene pues
bien veámoslo
el proceso constituyente chileno
queridos amigos amigas de visual
politiken chile existen dos tipos de
organismos que pueden redactar una
constitución o una vez claro está que se
aprueba en referéndum la iniciativa de
tener un nuevo texto constitucional
hablamos de lo que se conoce como la
convención mixta y la convención
constitucional que tiene algunas
diferencias importantes y de hecho en
esas diferencias está uno de los mayores
riesgos uno de los mayores peligros a
los que se enfrenta a chile'
próximamente pero de todo esto
hablaremos más tarde
la principal diferencia entre la
convención mixta y la constitucional es
quien elige a sus miembros en el caso de
la mixta se compone por 172
constituyentes de los cuales la mitad
son parlamentarios elegidos por el
congreso y la otra mitad son ciudadanos
elegidos a través de votación popular en
este caso la famosa regla de paridad
aprobada por la y por ambas cámaras del
congreso nacional obliga a que haya una
mitad de hombres y otra mitad de mujeres
pero sólo se aplica a los constituyentes
que son ciudadanos no a los
parlamentarios por contra la convención
constitucional tiene 155 miembros que
son todos ciudadanos elegidos por
votación popular y que deben ser sí o sí
mitad hombres y mitad mujeres
estamos hoy día frente a un hecho
histórico no solamente para nuestro país
sino que para el mundo acabamos de
aprobar una ley que permite que se
escriba la primera constitución
paritaria en la historia de la humanidad
y esa historia la escribimos acá la
escribimos en chile- y la opción que
ganó en el plebiscito nacional de
octubre del 2020 fue la de la convención
constitucional con lo que serán 155
ciudadanos los responsables de sacar
adelante la nueva constitución para su
funcionamiento de esta convención
constitucional que a todos los efectos
es una asamblea constituyente tendrá
fuertes limitaciones tanto temporales
como sobre su ámbito de actuación
[Música]
por ejemplo una vez se elijan sus
miembros y se active completamente la
convención tendrá sólo nueve meses
ampliables por tres más para redactar y
aprobar por mayoría de dos tercios el
nuevo texto completamente desde cero es
decir tienen un máximo de un año para
redactar y aprobar por mayoría reforzada
a todos y cada uno de los artículos
capítulos y bloques de la nueva
constitución un plazo ciertamente justo
que como veremos un poco más adelante
supone un importante riesgo
además la ley establece que la
convención constitucional es sólo podrá
dedicarse a redactar la nueva
constitución es decir no podrá
interferir en ningún otro asunto del
estado ni suplantar ni condicionar al
poder legislativo ejecutivo y judicial y
por supuesto deberá regirse bajo las
normas que están en vigor en la
actualidad en otras palabras para los
malpensados no hay relación con lo
ocurrido en venezuela donde la asamblea
constituyente constituida en 2017 ha
usurpado por completo desde entonces los
poderes de la asamblea nacional
convirtiéndose en un órgano legislativo
paralelo y antidemocrático además una
vez se acuerde y se ha votado por dos
tercios del texto final de la
constitución los ciudadanos deberán
refrendarlo lo que se conoce como
plebiscito de salida que es básicamente
una consulta de aprobación o rechazo a
la nueva constitución ahora bien una
momento antes de lanzar las campanas al
vuelo' lejos de las garantías legales
que convierten al proceso constituyente
chileno si en uno de los más limpios y
avanzados de latinoamérica lo cierto es
que los riesgos de hacer todo esto
precisamente ahora son muchos muchísimos
y he aquí amigos el dilema que existe en
toda esta cuestión y amigos podéis
creerme tal vez este es el punto más
peligroso fijaos
[Música]
una nueva constitución de alto voltaje
amigos las cosas son como son si hoy por
hoy hay algo que va a marcar
notablemente el proceso de redacción de
este nuevo texto constitucional en
chile- eso es precisamente su situación
social política y ahora también
económica y precisamente el hecho de
haber elegido a la convención
constitucional como el método para
llevarlo a cabo añade aún más riesgos a
este delicado tablero de juego
ante el estallido de violencia a las
movilizaciones y ahora también la crisis
económico y social producida por el
coronavirus la votación de los miembros
de la convención constituyente puede
llegar a suponer todo un peligro no es
ningún secreto que en los momentos en
los que la sociedad lo está pasando peor
que es cuando los movimientos radicales
tienen más oportunidades de alcanzar
amplias cotas de poder el claro el
riesgo más importante que surge de todo
este panorama es que los chilenos con
semejante situación política y ante todo
un estallido social elijan a una mayoría
de constituyentes con posiciones muy
radicales quizás muy ligadas a lo que se
ha venido a conocer en latinoamérica
como el socialismo del siglo 21 que de
moderno o moderado tal y como se ha
demostrado no tiene nada de nada
os imaginais no sé que participasen o
incluso que liberasen todo este proceso
personas que defienden al régimen de
venezuela oa las políticas de los
gobiernos de bolivia o argentina por
ejemplo ojo que no es una pregunta menor
si le ha sido la excepción en
latinoamérica a una sucesión constante
de grandes frustraciones y sueños rotos
porque si el país tiene muchos problemas
como por ejemplo un ascensor social que
no funciona bien o un sistema de
pensiones mal aplicado pero aún así
estos problemas no tienen nada que ver
con lo que es la norma a nivel regional
donde las cosas evidentemente y también
como vosotros sabéis son mucho muchísimo
peores a nivel regional chile ha sido un
modelo de éxito de democracia y
estabilidad durante las últimas tres
décadas y la pregunta que podemos
hacernos es garantizar a la nueva
constitución que lo esencial del
conocido como modelo chileno sigue en
pie y ojo porque es muy fácil prometer
todo tipo de derechos pero luego
hacerlos cumplir bueno eso digamos que
ya no resulta tan sencillo además la
constante violencia en la que los
chilenos han tenido que acostumbrar
durante último año podría ser empleada
por los radicales como un método de
presión contra los ciudadanos que están
redactando la nueva constitución y
encima por si no fuera suficiente la
corta limitación temporal de una
obligar a los constituyentes a darse
mucha pero que mucha prisa ya no debatir
demasiado cada artículo si quieren tener
el texto completamente aprobado a tiempo
para que me entendáis corremos el riesgo
de intentar curar una herida echándole
agua oxigenada hirviendo lo que por
supuesto claro está pues no es nada
recomendable puede que una nueva
constitución fuese necesaria pero era
éste el mejor momento para ponerse manos
a la obra
[Música]
y precisamente por eso existe mucha pero
que mucha preocupación sobre el tipo de
constitución que puede terminar saliendo
en estas condiciones desde luego no
parece que la nueva constitución vaya a
orientarse a limitar el poder del estado
y su presidente tal y como ocurre por
ejemplo en eeuu sino que más bien va a
terminar siendo seguramente un texto que
del estado enormes poderes muchas
responsabilidades y una gran
intervención pública sobre un montón de
cuestiones de la sociedad y la economía
es fácil decir que uno se quiere parecer
a países como suecia o noruega pero no
se corre el peligro quizás de terminar
pareciendo temas al modelo argentino ojo
que no es un proceso nada sencillo los
modelos escandinavos exigen mucha pero
que mucha competitividad algo con lo que
precisamente la economía chilena no
cuenta así que el riesgo está sobre la
mesa pero ha dicho esto turno para ti
tras conocer algunos detalles sobre la
carta magna de 1980 que es que chile
necesita una nueva constitución piensas
que este es el momento adecuado para
lanzarse a crear una nueva carta magna
como siempre déjanos tu respuesta aquí
abajo en los comentarios y si te ha
gustado este vídeo no olvides darle al
botón del aek y suscribirte a nuestro
canal para no perderte nada de lo que
está por venir una vez más muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la próxima
[Música]